sometimes when we talk about a political issue
on the show or a legal issue or a socio cultural
issue, two,
we talk and really specific technicalities.
Everything is couched in a variety of details
and sort of nuanced and sophisticated ways
with caveats and ifs and ands and buts.
And very often that's actually the right analysis
to do.
We want to be careful, we want to be thorough,
we want to be detailed.
And the problem with it is that sometimes
I, as much as anybody else, we'll end up kind
of getting lost in those details.
And I will to apply a common, a proverb or,
or term or metaphor or analogy, I will miss
the forest for the trees.
We forget that we're in a forest because we're
busy trying to count and measure every single
tree, for example.
And Hillary Clinton actually did something
clever last night on the Rachel Maddow show.
And this may come as a shock to many people
in our audience, but I'm not a Hillary fan
and I don't watch Rachel Maddow's show.
I don't really watch MSNBC.
The last time I talked about Rachel Maddow
was years ago when she bogusly hyped up having
Trump's tax returns.
And what she had was like the first page of
Trump's oh five return, which had nothing
interesting in it other than showing that
most of the tax that Trump paid, uh, was as
a result of the alternative minimum tax.
So people know Hillary's well to my right.
I don't watch these shows or whatever.
But this is actually a pretty interesting
clip.
Hillary Clinton said last night on the Rachel
Maddow show.
Hold on a second.
Let's step back for a moment in terms of Trump
and Russia.
And Mueller from was collusion or a obstruction
established, which evidence thresholds do
these different legal terms allude to exactly
how partisan was William bars handling of
this entire thing.
Hillary Clinton steps back from the trees
and says, let's look at the forest for a second.
And she lays out a really great hypothetical.
Imagine if a Democrat went on live television,
uh, and said, China, if you're listening,
going get Trump's taxes.
And then hours later the IRS got hacked and
Trump's taxes were released and we found out
that it was actually China who hacked and
provided those taxes to some third party,
like a Wiki leaks sort of organization.
Hillary Clinton is stepping back from the
trees and remembering that we're in the forest.
Take a look at what she said last night.
Since Russia is clearly backing Republicans.
Why don't we ask China to back us?
I hear by tonight ask China.
That's right.
And not only that, China, if you're listening,
why don't you get Trump's tax returns?
I'm sure our media would richly reward you.
Now, according to the Mueller report, that
is not conspiracy because it's done right
out in the open.
So if after this hypothetical Democratic candidate
says this on your show, within hours, all
of a sudden the IRS offices are bombarded
with incredibly sophisticated cyber tools
looking for Trump's tax returns and then extract
them and then passes them to whatever the
new wikileaks happens to be, and they start
being unraveled and disclosed.
Nothing wrong with that.
So the point of playing this is not to, uh,
uh, Praise Hillary.
I mean, I thought that she was a bad candidate
and she's well to my right, the point of this
is not to, to, to revisit the idea that Trump
personally colluded with Putin.
I told you 13 months ago, go back and look
that it is not going to be the outcome of
the Mueller probe.
That's not how these things work.
It's not Trump getting on the phone with Putin
and saying, how can we work together to, to
help me win?
This is just a good reminder that sometimes
we've got to zoom out to understand the picture
of what's going on and the context, uh, and
get away from the minutia that often becomes
the focus in many analyses of the molar report.
Now, I can't believe that I have to do what
I'm about to do.
I bet some of you may maybe even fell for
this.
Unfortunately, there are a ton of right wing
news outlets and so called commentators and
analysts who seized on the clip I just played
for you, which is Hillary Clinton with a hypothetical
thought experiment, right?
And they are claiming that Hillary called
for China to hack Trump's taxes.
Okay.
Can you imagine being so disconnected from
reality and so lost that you fall for the
claim that when Hillary says, here's a thought
experiment that she is actually calling for
China to hack Donald Trump's taxes.
And if the right has successfully bamboozled
you into thinking that, then I feel sorry
for you.
Uh, but, but I feel obligated to just mention
that there are actually people on the right
claiming that that clip was Hillary publicly
calling for the illegal hacking of Donald
Trump's taxes by China.
And the funny thing about that is the people
who are attacking Hillary for the thought
experiment don't seem to care that Donald
Trump actually did it.
Like Trump actually called for Russia to Hack
Hillary and the DNC.
And then Russia did.
And then they gave the data to wikileaks,
which Trump used to say that he loved, but
now all of a sudden claims to barely even
remember who they were.
Uh, and the only conclusion that I came to
after reviewing the reactions to this clip
from right wing media was that we're in trouble.
We're in trouble as a country, we're in trouble
as a society.
And we are so far down the rabbit hole of
a total lack of critical thinking and media
literacy that, uh, I wish I could be more
optimistic about the future, but I'm not based
on how many people fell for this stupid miss
characterization of what Hillary Clinton did
last night.
Disclaimer, I didn't vote for her in the primary
and she's to my right and this is not talking
about how Great Hillary Clinton is.
She's just made an interesting
point last night.